hey guys welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam Bash and while we're all
recovering from infinity war Marvel
decide to throw us a bone and drop the
official second trailer for ant-man and
the wasp thing God cuz things were
getting dark anywho before we dive into
the quantum realm with our ETB friends
here just for the warning for ant-man
and the wasp anywho play the trailer so
how long have you been ant-man again no
huh I just sort of happened like bad
guys like you
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time Marais cassie's back man
I know it would be a long shot but I'd
love to see a future version of the next
generation of heroes in the MCU maybe we
could get a glimpse at her as her hero
persona like in the comics usually she
has a couple different names like aunt
girl but my personal favorite is stature
and she's usually got a cool costume I
mean I wouldn't mind but moving on we
see a man is back in San Francisco his
home turf and we know that he's under
house rust thanks to the arrangement
that he set up with the US government
after the events of Civil War
infinity war I'm hoping that this is the
first scene between Cassie and Scott
just one-on-one and I'm excited to see
him strive to be a better papa in this
movie I think what Cassie is referring
to here about being ant-man again could
be a reference to civil war and this
could be a cute scene where he recounts
the airport fight or possibly he's just
talking about this specific movie that
he's in right now all I know is that
Scott using a flatbed truck as one of
those one nice scooter things you see at
Disneyland is one of my new favorite
scenes why would he need to use that I
thought possibly maybe a leg injury
would prevent him from running after
that car but as far as I could tell his
legs are fine
maybe being at that size makes it harder
to move fast so why not get a little
assistance then the following shot is up
Scott catching up with Walton Goggins
character Sonny birch in his Escalade
now Sonny birch is from the comics if
you didn't know he usually is associated
with cross technologies which we are
aware of thanks to the first ant-man
movie to remember the villain
yellowjacket his real name was Darren
cross and he was attempting to rename
Pym tech cross technologies also fun
fact
Sonny Burgess has a very small role in
the comics he just did a four-issue run
in an Iron Man story where he attempted
to gain control of the patent behind the
Iron Man costume and recreated and sell
it so maybe that story is being you know
applied to Pym tech and the ant-man suit
in general if he's trying to steal that
building so he could see all the tech
goodies were profit maybe also weird
they edited out the Cadillac logo on
that Escalades grille that car was in
the first trailer and you could see the
logo there maybe they got
not a super interesting easter egg next
clip maybe you just need some watch for
back like a partner I love this scene
love the ant-man really has to try to
stop this car he really skied the truck
to a stop and you also get that comedic
element of no one noticing inside the
coffee shop that ant-man just slidin
down the street more like a giant man am
i right it's not a joke that's of his
name is but most importantly let's check
out the wasps takedown of all these
evildoers inside this SUV this must be
one of the cars following sunny birches
since they're all different henchmen
based on the other cars to line up let's
all celebrate whenever we get an awesome
take down inside of a moving car and I'm
getting some serious Deadpool vibes
during this scene specifically the SUV
fight scene we got the beginning of
Deadpool where Wade is hunting for
Francis it's an amazing scene now the
final scene of this clip looks to be a
snippet of the lobby fight scene from
the previous trailer and boys Evangeline
Lilly looking like a badass next clip
dr. Pym I actually heard what happened
to you do open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be gold so
that walks through walls of stuff solely
otech
now supposed to take over the world or
whatever
Louisa's back the MCU is saved what a
great character to give us a wrap-up as
to what's going on didn't really give us
any details and I'm still confused but
hey I love him
this scene does give us a hint as to
what Lewis and the gang have been up to
since the first ant-man movie those all
those security cameras in the background
and the keypad guarded lock interesting
well it looks like our guys have gone
straight and turned to helping people
protect their valuables instead of
stealing them keep boys they have a
pretty fun business name also that's
teased throughout this trailer I'll come
back to that just a second cuz I want to
here we also have Lewis saying that he
knows what happened to Hank Pym in the
next shot we see is of a big green
button and Hank Pym inside that ship we
saw in the first trailer I'm guessing
that button is inside that ship I mean
Porsche if you're scientist you have put
a big important button inside your ship
to make it go are you an idiot now based
on this setup it looks like this is just
moments before he heads off possibly
alone into the quantum realm Hank Pym
now too old to do this
the next shot we get is of the ship
flying through some rainbow golden
energy which seems reminiscent of the
doctor strange magic specifically the
daggers that kycilia seen his goons are
using to attacked Doctor Strange but
also this energy can be seen behind the
ship before it takes off snown as that
up in that tube and then also it pops up
later on but I'll get back to that in
just a second this Pym tech could play a
very important role in this movie so
keep your eyes open also notice that
when the ship flies through this energy
Hank is definitely alone flying the ship
there could be someone in the back seat
but it looks like he's flying solo
perfect next we see him donning a suit
and heading out into the quantum realm
alone now whatever this material around
him is I'm not sure but this is
obviously the start of a rescue mission
for Janet Van Dyne aka the original wasp
aka
Hanks a boy who was lost in the quantum
realm a few decades ago this realm does
look you know similar to the way that
the dark dimensions energies moved
around in Doctor Strange during that
Dormammu fight not so much of a fight
more of a bargain but you get it but
also notice this that rainbow golden hue
of the energy we saw earlier is in the
background of this entire scene that
Energy's popping up again
interesting next we get a name job for
the crazy creepy ghost that stole Hanks
tech now it almost sounds like the
quantum realm opened and ghost was set
free from the realm based on how fast
Luisa is talking just want to bring that
up some people tweeted me asking about
that but I don't think that's how it all
went down my guess that this is just the
timeline of events that Luis knows them
as and he's just explaining them or it
could just be how the trailers edited
I don't think ghost was specifically
hiding in the quantum realm but I think
maybe ghost was exposed to the energies
from the quantum realm
now who is ghost get a little head of
myself there well Erik Voss great
powerful did explain who she is in the
first ant-man breakdown but quickly
explanation she's usually the key in the
comics and usually an Iron Man villain
but ghosts can phase their object and
he's usually an industrial saboteur
found that descriptor online and I dug
it not going to take credit for it
we even see her using those phasing
abilities to get through a door but pay
attention here it almost looks like you
see multiple versions of her pushing the
door open a bunch of different ways
maybe her specific abilities have her
tapping into the quantum realm and you
see all the possible ways she could have
gotten through that door and her body
picked the easiest one by phasing
through it hoo boy it is I did a little
bit too big for me but maybe something
similar is happening but let's keep
going the next scene is of her fighting
ant-man in her kicking Scott crew whoa
so I'm guessing whatever happened to her
enhanced her physiology but also noticed
that we get the same clip from the first
trailer of ghosts in a chamber with you
guessed it the same energy we saw in
PIMs lab and in the quantum realm my
guess is that this is some sort of
experimental radiation for Pym particles
or probably possibly radiation harness
from the quantum realm and she's getting
a big old dose of it or maybe she's
letting off all that energy in that room
and she's trying to be contained either
way ghosts got ahold of it and then
either her experiment went poorly or she
used it as a weapon because it ends up
ripping apart this warehouse notice all
the energy is being using this explosion
RUP row next clip who do believe that in
your hour of need you would turn the
house happy because we robbed you do you
remember that's us
feel and chassis practice is oh the deal
and man in the wash team enough here's
another clip of these agents cornering
Hank and hope in this field and based on
their outfits this is probably the same
day as their meeting with lluís and his
company knows the sweater vests on Hank
in both scenes now why are they hunting
them down why so many people possibly
because Scott Lang has ditched his GPS
locater come back to that in a second
and they're looking form so they're
going to is you know main context maybe
they stole another building and people
are starting to get a little peeved or
maybe these are private sector security
people who work for sunny birch fine
ideas here just saying let me know what
you think in the comments down below
either way at some point the PIMs are
going to need some help from here's the
name I t's ex-con security solutions get
it as they are all in jail they robbed
people before specific way kingpin
remember anyhoo the name of this company
is teased all over the place on their
t-shirts on their mugs on the computer
screens and it's spelled x - con next we
get a shot of ghosts glitching which if
I were to guess isn't making her feel
too good she looks dope though gotta be
honest that's one of the best costumes
in the MCU also loved to point out the
twist on the line we've heard over and
over again in these types of movies the
only chance to save the world is you you
know classic but in this movie it's you
too cuz they gotta work together the
next look we get is up hope a bit teary
eyed and based on the previous trailer
this looks like this could be the same
room where that quantum realm Explorer
vehicle from earlier is being housed and
possibly this is where Hank is going to
enter the quantum realm I'm pointing
this out mainly because remember that
giant Duracell battery in the last
trailer well there it is again in the
background with that in mind why would
she be upset maybe she's seeing someone
she thought had been lost years ago
maybe this scene is when we finally get
to see Janet for the first time finally
we get wasp doing an awesome take down
in that same lobby from earlier with
ant-man name-dropping both of them fun
next all my lead
she seems more intense the team is on
the move ant-man and the wasp look to be
going after some patties in the hotel
possibly leading to an awesome kitchen
fight scene and we saw in the first
trailer and this trailer by the way
that's a lot of salt to spill as a whole
heck of a lot of bad luck next we get a
very confusing scene this is most likely
the hint from the first movie that
became in bigand after the you know epic
fight scene at the end of the movie and
is now a pet for Cassie it's playing
electric drums and it's wearing
headphones and most importantly it's got
tracker bracelet on its southernmost leg
now I have two theories here one this is
a dream sequence that makes the most
sense Scott is maybe feeling cooped up
in the house or maybe on a drug trip and
he just sees himself as an aunt number
two that this is actually happening an
aunt is playing drums in the house and
the reason for wearing the bracelet is
because Scott put it on the end so that
he could slip out and fight crime but
how could it play drums the last clip I
want to show you is of Scott diving off
of an ant to avoid a seagull but notice
in the background looking awful blue
donut much like the San Francisco Bay
possibly this is when Scott jumps into
the water and then in Biggums himself in
front of the ferry next
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
here we see the wasp flying into the
kitchen area once again from the hotel
lobby so it's fair to assume that she's
about to kick multiple asses makes me a
glimpse of ant-man floating in the
quantum realm now this could be a
flashback to when he was floating around
in the first movie but maybe this is
happening in this film the pay attention
here when something flies past him
rather quick you pay very close
attention you slow it down frame by
frame you'll notice that this object was
annexed to have a head and set of wings
sort of like we've been hanging out down
here for quite some time but I don't
remember her moving that quickly maybe
hanging out in the quantum realm has
made her a little bit faster next we get
another creepy shot of ghost walking
towards camera possibly from the scene
she can't scott through the wall and
then a shot of ant-man of the wasp
coordinating attack from within the same
room as the quantum realm ship the next
shot is of wasp kicking the crap out of
ghosts so maybe this is the final or at
least one of the final showdowns in this
movie maybe it happens inside of this
room hopefully this isn't the reason why
I hope is crying I don't want ghosts to
hurt anyone I like also wanted to say
that my guess is that this room is
within the building that everyone's
playing hot potato with the next clip is
the one we should all be focusing on and
hits up ant-man and the wasp taken down
a soldier now there's a lot to notice
here like how this is actually the older
design of the ant-man costume
interesting from the first movie why
would Scott be wearing that also the
uniform of the soldier looks to be
similar to the uniforms of the soldiers
that ant-man fought in the past if you
remember from that footage that Darren
cross the label would get in the first
amp and movie so maybe this is hang
interesting so maybe this is a flashback
so if that's true who's the wasp well
notice the color scheme of the costume
it's not so much like the present-day
costume so this is probably the show
play first oh how fun this scene though
will make me very excited when I see it
on the big screen next
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny all
right come to the end of this trailer we
see ghost phasing through an SUV and
taking down a motorcyclist with a gun so
maybe there's multiple parties in this
venture
maybe ghost is a solo enemy and Walton
Goggins is on his own little mission
trying to steal a building we get it
that's the rat race right everyone's
hustling
but anyways next we see a bunch of cars
flip and one of these shots is the same
as a previous trailer but this new one
looks to be of a car flipping down the
famous lombard street in san francisco
with lewis and wasp avoiding bricks and
rubble as it crashes around them and
we're left with scott popping up in the
back of the car asking what he missed we
didn't get our awesome title card and
we're out but we are left with one more
fun scene let's play it I was partners
with Hank on a project called Goliath
how big did you get my record 21 feet
you've 65 feet 65
if you to our finish comparing sizes 65
fun way to end this trailer here we have
Laurence Fishburne as Bill Foster
aka Goliath from the comics hence the
codename for their project being Goliath
which seems to be a project that
probably meant they were making super
tall soldiers maybe I will say this
break you when they're comparing sizes
weird sentence no Foster's most well
known for being a scientist in the
comics friend of Hank Pym and Goliath
the size changing hero that uses his
bigger
he was also giant man at one point but
I'm not sure we're gonna get a tall
version of Billy in this movie but if we
did like in the flashback scene I'd be
fine with it finally we get this shot of
ant-man rising out of the bay next to
the ferry that Walton Goggins is using
to escape with the shrunken building one
final note shout out to the superhero
epic version of it takes two I'm a fan
but that's it kids here's my question
for you two actually how do you think go
stumbles upon these powers also why
would an ant wear headphones it's
bugging the crap out of me let me know
in the comments down below also let me
know if I missed anything in the
comments or on Twitter at Sam bash or
like this video share and subscribe for
more content we got a lot i'm sam basher
if you want you can check out my podcast
toy stupid answers i talked about nerdy
stuff all the time i'll see you guys
next time